hey this is funny so many of you know
this guy named Jesse Lee Peterson he's a
70 year old black religious conservative
I've been on his show I've appeared in
his studio in Los Angeles at his
Christian men's Counseling Center yeah
when I was last in Los Angeles or not
last actually a couple times ago maybe
it was the last time now I don't even
remember it's all blur he was recently
either he was interviewed by or he
interviewed another conservative Trump
esteemed Nick DiPaolo
now if you've not heard of Nick DiPaolo
the DePalo I don't know how he
pronounces the last name Nick DiPaolo is
a 57 year old trumpet comedian from the
Boston area shockingly enough and the
topic came up when they were talking to
each other of apparently Jesse Lee
Peterson seems to think that he and I
are debating at politican this weekend
now I'll talk more about that in a
second and they took it as an
opportunity I guess to frame me as some
idealistic wide-eyed naive 18 year old
political correctness socialist lefty or
something like that take a look at this
clip well he's actually gonna be a
debating a David Pakman at a politican
on October 27th in Nashville please
welcome Jesse Lee Petersen Jesse how are
you all this well thank you so much for
having me Michael appreciate it my
pleasure Jesse yeah by the way I said
earlier I really liked you you look
sharp in the background yeah I'm not I'm
not good with my hands but we we filed
the cheap place where I could save about
2 grand a month and me my me my
producers were at Home Depot you know
all weekend buying plywood and
two-by-fours and somehow we got it all
together
yeah we yeah and we loved it much better
actually it's a it's more intimate and
yeah I'm proud of people saying nice
things about it let me ask you Jesse
yeah
first things first who's this guy you're
debating and do you need help because he
sounds like a punk no I'm just kidding
Oh who's David Pakman you know I've had
him on my my TV show
the state TV believe me been on the
radio show some play that he's just
another little young liberal who has no
idea of what are you doing or what he's
talking about he's windows intellectuals
who has no sense of common sense at all
so I'm trying to help him find his way
back home it's a nice way of putting it
how do these how do these kids get so
locked kids I'm well I'm 57 I guess I
can say it how do they get so lost Jesse
today and why are they so susceptible to
a lot of this left-wing PC garbage
culture they seem to ingest it I know
goes back to college campuses and even
further back how do you undo that how
are you gonna get this guy home well
it's really due to the lack of fathers
we you don't have a father and a mother
who are perfect examples for you if the
father's not the head of his wife and
their children then the mother tend to
take over and women tend to be emotional
and so the boys the girls are turned
away from the father so they take on
that the thoughts and ideas of their
mothers and the feelings so when they go
out into the world it's easy to deceive
them because they are women tend to be
intellectual and men tend to be logical
it's also funny to me what when you
watch something like this Nick DiPaolo
seems to be talking to Jesse Lee
Peterson like Jesse Lee Peterson is a
serious political person which is just
precious and hilarious and it's not the
approach I've taken when I when I do
stuff with Jesse but you know left-wing
political correctness that's not this
show that's not me that's never what it
has been how to get me home they want to
figure out a lack of a father I have a
father and there's no no problem there
and hilariously if you looked at the
live chat while they were broadcasting
this the comments aren't just about me
being you know girly man feminized [ __ ]
liberal as the problem a lot of the
people in the live chat were saying no
no the problem with David Pakman is he's
one of these Jew liberals that's a real
problem anyway clearly society is going
to progress as a result of the political
discourse that happens when a 70 year
old and a 57 year old make fun of a 35
year old who isn't even there to defend
himself on the basis of incorrect
allegations right this is really how
we're gonna solve the world's problems
now let's get to the political thing I
am confused about why Jesse Lee Peterson
believes that he's debating me at
politican I'm not going to politican I
have no tickets to Nashville I have a
weekend of social and family gatherings
planned people have notified me that
politican on their website listed an
event that shows me debating Jesse Lee
Peterson I think on Sunday at like 3 or
4 p.m.
and I have no idea why my manager was in
discussions with politican we never got
an offer in writing with all of the
parameters and logistics that had sort
of been mentioned verbally and they have
it scheduled for a time Sunday afternoon
where even if I were to go I wouldn't be
able to do it at that time we had
problems getting to travel together
I was waiting around for a written offer
for something like six weeks in any case
nothing happened I was never going to
politican never had flights to Nashville
never signed a contract there's actually
I'm kind of being careful because
there's actually a lot more to this
story I don't think it's appropriate for
me to tell it right now
but much like Sam cedar had a story to
tell about politican and he waited
nearly a year to tell that story he
recently told it it relates to steven
crowder I also have a story to tell
about politican which maybe I will
someday tell but not today
and a lot of my friends are going to
politican and participating and I don't
want to get anybody in trouble throw
anybody under the bus or do anything but
there is a story to tell in any case I
was never going to politican I will not
be there I'm not debating Jesse Lee
Peterson I have no idea what he will be
doing or what he thinks he will be doing
it's it's all kind of a
nebulous very sort of opaque situation
but I will not be at pilota con for
everybody who's been emailing me and
asking about it